what's up guys alright so and today what
we're going to do we are going to
interview a quant now what is a quant a
quant is usually called a quantitative
researcher or a quantitative analyst
what they do is they work for hedge
funds I think what they do is they use
mathematical model of Statistics you
know all these rigorous tools to try to
predict a market or try to you know
think about good investment strategies
for hedge fund to make tons of tons of
money and why do I want to interview a
quant
is because it is the highest paying job
like if you come out of college and you
go straight to a quant you can get up to
like starting salary like $200,000 and
also that's not even what's most
appealing about it it's the bonuses now
the bonuses they can go up to like half
a mil you know it's not a surprise that
after you worked there for four years
you might get a total compensation of a
million dollars a year so we are going
to interview a quant and also this is a
little bit special because this quant is
my brother so yeah I hope you enjoy the
interview welcome to the Johno show
it's not called don't show anymore
because now I'm doing vlogs but I know
it hasn't been a while since I've done
an interview
and today we have a special guest David
mAh so he is a special person highly
requested because he used to work as a
quant at 2 Sigma is that correct that's
correct
that is cool so a little intro questions
that I usually ask to all my viewers so
Mac or PC Mac easy I'm more Android
iPhone I'm boy you're a fanboy yep see
favorite language Spanish Spanish yeah
this sounds really nice
favorite programming laughing all right
so I said if you think people always
make that mistake on my own language you
know I don't really care mm-hmm I use
Java now I like that I like oh yeah is
Java yep Wow like on your startup yeah
we'll talk about this later
what about favorite editor
Microsoft Word also ambiguous because
the IDS aren't really nice now these
days but I used to use them otherwise
yeah yeah mm-hmm
I mean honestly I used them because of
you yeah because in case you mean and
then you gotta suck it up yeah pretty
much
learn all these commands and stuff but
yeah I remember you started then because
you were that Facebook right day me no
no no vim was first-year University okay
SSH like I had to use something mmm and
then was one of the choices and like
people now I see I said it was good but
then I really got good at Facebook
because I mean that was a pretty much
one of the only choices oh wait I got
one more in user submitted tabs or
spaces obviously what you press space oh
you mean like tab identity becomes yeah
not a lot of space yeah yeah that's a
big big differentiator yeah all right
cool so I heard you are a quantitative
researcher that is correct yeah so wait
where'd you work again two sigma Oh
interesting
I didn't know that well you're a bad
brother
yeah all right cool so ok what is 2
Sigma exactly 2 Sigma is a quantitative
hedge fund mmm they use mathematics
statistics computer science to make
money on the stock markets on various
financial markets cool cool and then as
a quant what I do there's different
types of points the stuff that I did was
to find to predict the movements of
stock prices ok and through you know
statistics I see so basically do a lot
of like forecasting forecasting yeah
that's a good word ok cool so you're
trying to predict movements and then
you're gonna bet on that and stuff like
that and then you probably have like a
lot of different what else do you have
to do it you have to have like I heard a
lot of them the term what is it
alpha yeah was that yeah so alpha is
just a term to signify that you've
you're able to predict the market better
than the average person on the market oh
god I got it
okay so hired alpha yeah it's better
higher offer the bedroom cap there's gay
seems pretty simple just a quick
question how much stats background or
math background do you need to be
successful as a quant
because is it like do you have to be
genius you know did you do competitions
definitely not it's good to have a solid
understanding like a basic understanding
of statistics to not make the worst
mistakes like personally I took third
year stats third and fourth year stats
at Waterloo which is not it's not
graduate level or anything like that
mm-hmm but basically the the most
important things I think is to have
creativity and to think critically about
your data and like about the process
where that data was generated I think
that's more much more important than
like the actual statistics right so what
you mean creativity what do you mean the
reason why I ask is because I would
think I need creativity as a data
scientist but also because I think I'm a
lot less technical than you in terms of
like stats knowledge because a lot of
the times I'm just like they're just
average these things up and then they
just take that very that's even if
there's they're like cool like whole
correlated right what's creativity for
you so I mean just talk about those kind
of stats like that's actually kind of
enough as long as you're aware of where
your biases are right your effects are
so much larger than whatever bias like
it doesn't matter like that's a good
case but yeah when you're trying to find
like tiny differences then sure it'll
matter but hopefully that's not the case
because you want to find a lot of alpha
right and that's where the creativity
comes in you want to find things that
other people have not thought of maybe
like oh let's use satellite imagery to
look at how full wells are in order to
predict some commodity prices and stuff
like that that was creative yeah at some
point it became not created because you
know I want to do a lot of here got it
so are you saying that like strategies
like for hedge funds
if you're the only one doing it you
might be profitable but if everyone
starts doing it
that's correct becomes less profitable
it's called crowdedness mmm interesting
so I heard you know especially from
friends at Citadel that they work super
long hours you know it's hard and then a
lot of times when I ask software
engineers if they would like to switch
to finance because they know that
finance they pay a lot you know but then
they always come with the excuse saying
yeah but I don't want that like crazy
work hours so is it true like the you
work long hours
it depends on the like personally at 2
Sigma it was not that long i I think I
averaged 10 hours 10 hours a day okay
and it's not like it's not 10 hours of
like intense you have to be always on
like first of all that was research this
that's what I did software engineering
is probably even less hours at 2 Sigma
mm-hmm the culture at 2 Sigma was like
of someone of a balanced culture between
life and work so they wanted people that
would come in and not you know have a
good have a good life not leave a lot
leave too soon
mmm yeah that makes sense it's it might
be true in other companies that 2 Sigma
was pretty balanced yeah do you have any
friends who came from Silicon Valley
then worked at finance or worked in
finance then Silicon Valley and how do
you know how they compare like I think
it was pretty similar pretty simple yeah
of course the the things that you're
working on was pretty different yeah but
like to say might try to make you know a
Silicon Valley style culture do you
think it's the same for like Citadel and
like other finance companies it's hard
to know
I mean I've never been there like they
are competitors they work yeah
no it's nice ok so let's talk about your
background so how did you get into Kwan
like first how did you discover it and
what do you think like your background
should be to me you know to get an
interview right at least the first time
that I heard about like quants
was in my CJ I had it I had this
professor he was like it was 2007 right
financial crash and like they're like
housing crisis and stuff like that he
was like blaming oh it's the cons like
that's the bad stuff they use their
mathematical models of to to create
financial disaster I was talking to my
friend I was like oh yeah that's my god
that's why I want to be you know and you
actually became one I didn't know what
it what it was because like at that time
I wanted to be an actuarial major
because I was like oh I like math let's
let's see what I can do with math and
that's all I knew but like through the
years at at Waterloo
you know I learn how to code I learned
about predictive statistics and then at
some point near the end I was like well
all these things together well it was a
good fit for mmm for it to be a yeah
research Kwanza so what was your major
in University of Waterloo mathematics
mathematics at Waterloo is very
ambiguous yeah you can like take
whatever you want
so you take stats where were you like a
math genius like did you do contests I
mean I did contests when I was in high
school ranked 2nd in Quebec would oh oh
I didn't know about other you didn't
know that oh yeah
only there's only one competition that
ranked second I was like my peak mmm
but otherwise no I wouldn't consider
myself genius in any way it was more
combination of multiple things that led
to guy yeah he's like computer science
stats and some interest in finance
hmm so if you had to tell a high
schooler like my boy Matt show behind a
camera or like an early college student
yeah they want to be a quant you really
want to be a quant mhm like don't even
tell me if it's actually my passion or
not but just I just want to be cool okay
what do you do right now
computer science mm-hmm
stats do some keggle competitions I
think that's good haggle that is one
thing they discovered pretty early on
and I ranked like some somewhere the top
10 for a competition this is not a
humble bragging interview for you that's
not saying that you're still fun okay
that was at the time when it was easy
very cool all right
it was easier honestly because now like
there's like so many PhDs like I'm super
competitive okay on Kegel it's a it's
overcrowded yes that's right all right
so what about like um like interviewing
at these companies how hard is it or
like what kind of questions do you ask I
would say it's hard because maybe not
because other questions they ask but
because so many people want to apply
like these days I wonder if if I apply
now whether I wouldn't get in it's kind
of a what kind of questions do they ask
technical questions obviously you have
to know your computer science you have
to know your statistics I spent a whole
day just going through all these
questions that people compiled online
okay where do you find these questions
like behind the crate in the coding
interview yeah cracking the code that's
a glass door there's like some quant one
that people have compiled like more
statistics and like more probability
questions brain teasers like just go
through all of them it's like just to
maximize your chances huh these honestly
I don't think it's like a really good
you don't it's not like you use this
under on the job especially the brain
teasers but it kind of filters out the
people who are like I'm gonna do
although this rare array okay so
basically hard-working people yeah it's
it's it filters with some training yeah
in conclusion from what I understand
Kwan's
you know they they're basically like
data scientists I feel like they're a
little bit more rigorous you know they
use mathematical models to try to
predict the markets so that it can make
money for the hedge fund it's good
summer and cold alright so let's talk
about a little bit of it you know you as
a person
because we want to know like how does
one have an interesting tip Juan so
thinking about when you were a kid do
you think you have like behaviors where
it kind of indicated that you're more a
technical person a more mathematical
person you know hmm like for me I was
yeah so yeah you can go Chris oh well
for me I think it was just like playing
games they're like RTS then you know how
you had to manage money or stuff like
that or also like building stuff in
Kingdom Hearts oh yeah you know that
that would be a very engineering jessamy
yeah that was very impressive I really
enjoyed reading detective stories oh
yeah I don't know how that relates to
the Kwan because you have to investigate
data right I find out like as a data
scientist it's it's kind of like a
you're kind of like a detective but your
your subject is data you have things
that you want to investigate and you
have to like find ways of like answering
that question through evidence I like
the I really like that analogy because
it feels like in the end the data is
just data and then all the statistic Kol
knowledge yeah and if you're really
technical it doesn't make you a better
data scientist right what's important
right is the questions you ask and how
you get those answers and also like
being able to take synthesize all the
evidence that you that you've you found
and into like one coherent story right
that's like a very detective thing to do
right right because like if there's one
like if there's like one piece of
evidence that doesn't fit with the story
it's something's wrong right right okay
cool so what about the side one now what
do you do outside of work aside from you
know when you actually work what are
your hobbies
um Eddie photography in bed these days
was it like an Instagram I mean it's not
that good Jumana paw I haven't haven't
done much dinner in a while wait your
handles actually at David MA yeah so
lucky I also have David MA
hmm yeah you could check out the website
it's pretty plain
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] yeah I need it
some sort of designer contact me the
enemy
well it's literally just a text yeah and
it's and it's super updated it says I'm
a client that oh yeah not sure anymore
oh right true yeah so you're not a
quantity more so what do you do now I
work at a startup we're still very small
we are building a real estate agent
assistance and we help real estate
agents schedule things with prospects
managers schedules collect data about
their performances so that you know this
can this stuff can be automated so that
they can focus on the stuff they do best
which is selling to people who come in
cool cool you guys doing well pretty
well I think pretty well nice is on my
disc or channel I also asked them to ask
UK you questions or us questions how to
get your little brother a girlfriend
it's hopeless
it's hopeless that's what with yeah why
do you think is hopeless what's what's
wrong with me
I have theories but what do you think
well I was actually kidding he's
actually tons of girls he just doesn't
tell you guys that's not sure it's not
part of my brand next question what was
Joma like when he was younger less
confidence oh really yes that's true
yeah that's true I think that summarizes
the biggest the biggest difference yeah
mm-hmm all right if next question
favorite video game oh yeah um probably
smash oh really yeah yeah that makes
sense I mean I hate that you're better
than me I'm so good but like it's really
it's a really good smash melee yeah you
never got one of them to learn the
advanced techniques though yeah it's
true
that's what you're not blocked yeah yeah
I was like like try to break that I like
who is smarter Jomar David I'm gonna
give us serious answer for this well
really yeah yes serous I'm sorry when as
a kid
I thought I was smarter no I think you I
think you're still are smarter because
as a kid all right like in the earlier
stages I thought look oh yeah
like IQ tests and like math they're like
being clever at those kind of things was
meant that you were smarter and I think
I'm better than that that kind of stuff
but I realized like after some
university and like especially after
after that there's so many ways of being
smart and I kind of find that in general
like I find you learn things faster than
me and I think now I think you're you're
smarter than me thank you
what kind of music are you have put on
this I don't know I'll have to think
about it I think you're you're smarter
than me man tonight
toric you sir offices some yeah but yeah
definitely like thank you first of all
it's very nice for you to say but no it
was not that clear is not that charity
right wasn't gentlemen no thank you
thank you yeah yeah but I do want to say
like yeah definitely like quantitative
wise and stuff like that you were always
like smarter sometimes it did feel like
I was like living under your shadow in
some ways right again it's cute I'll
leave that ya know but but yeah like I'm
glad like hopefully someday I feel like
cuz you in some ways paved the way for
me internet like my education what I did
and stuff like that mm-hm I just hope
that one day I can like give back you
know I think you are already doing it at
scale kinda really yeah thank you
cool you don't have a smaller younger
brother but yeah you're doing what you
can
mm-hmm I think in the end like whenever
we're successful
you should just lead the way for some
other people romantic man Beckett I'm
just I'm just trying to make money on my
youtube channel alright so thank you for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to like and subscribe and if you
want to see some of my brothers
photography it's at David MA
[Music]
acting up food days nothing to deny